so is it fair to say that people were
more naive 2000 years ago than today
not even in what person naive in a way
that it was easier to control the
populace 2000 years ago versus today
you think it's easier to control the
populace today or two thousand years ago
probably today really you think that
you think today versus two thousand
years ago why do you think because i
think we're more connected and everybody
seems to have a platform
on which they can
put out their belief or you know their
thoughts two thousand years ago we
didn't have all the technology where
everybody could have their own little
podcast or show where they could put
their thoughts out there it was a pretty
limited
way that a message could be put out sure
so doesn't that make it easier to get
more of the populace to believe one
message two thousand years ago than
today
possibly right possibly okay so where
today
you know you see the the church
attendance down you see you know uh
tithing is down you see all this data
that's coming out right you go to
churches you're like okay they're having
a hard time with their argument and
messaging some churches are growing lds
church is growing there's some you know
uh uh
sanks you know that that are grown but
for the most part you'll hear a lot of
people say church attendance is down you
see that data all over the place it's
not i'm not the one that's talking about
this
but going back to it like i look at my
kids when melva who is mexican our nanny
she's a catholic
and i remember watching her the way she
would make the kids eat food at night
and i would watch her and she would say
tico you better eat this food because
coyotes are coming coyotes are coming
and she would look outside the window
coyotes are outside
and my son would eat the food oh my gosh
coyotes are coming so i'm sitting i'm
like what the hell is coyote okay at
this point the only thing i can link
oyota too is it sounds like coyote so is
it is she but there's no way in the
world she's saying the coyotes are
coming to come and eat my
sister and i said jen what is what is
coyote is kyoto what i think it is she
says yeah it's coyotes
okay i said so this woman's been telling
these kids coyotes are coming a few
thousand times
one day these kids are going to be 38
years old and they're going to be afraid
to go back outside in a backyard because
they're afraid there's coyotes there
because when they were kids somebody
told them coyotes are
so now this somebody might say come on
patrick what a ludicrous argument you're
making here but i think there's a way to
control the populace through fear
and and the way to do that is to
convince them that there is such thing
as the devil
that he can control you and he can harm
you and he can do all these things to
you
and then you see people getting scared
and it's so much easier through
imagination to control them back then
maybe not as much today maybe it's still
effective i don't know now again this is
the argument
i would make years ago
and there was always a different uh
rebuttal to it i'm curious to know what
you say to this when you hear
maybe we have to convince the populace
there is the devil and then let their
imagination convince them that they are
possessed and sometimes our imagination
can take us to some wild places and do
some wild things and some crazy things
and uh things that don't exist what do
you say to that
i would say that you know the church's
stance on the devil isn't meant to
scare people i mean the church proposes
but it doesn't impose
i think to me it's not about having
people live in fear the focus should be
on people living in love which is
basic premise you know of the new
testament god is love
and how do people experience that notion
of god see i would say that you talk
about declining
you know church attendance
the number of people who believe in god
is in decline
for me it's because people don't have a
proper
understanding of who god is
you know if you were to ask people who
is god what is god
what response would you get
creator they would go to
go ahead
but i think for the most part people
would come up with a concept of god
that's based on fear the hellfire and
brimstone
so i do think a lot of people today and
this is only my opinion where people
have a distorted image of god
and to me the ministry of exorcism
really is trying to help people have a
better understanding of who or what god
is so really the focus is not on the
devil and people might be surprised with
that response
but it's really
about helping people understand who god
is and what god wants to do in their
life so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]